the 48th red flag exercises underway at
Nellis 8 news now reporter Brian will
was at the base today and tells us why
this operation is so important for the
U.S and our allies
flight line here at Nellis Air Force
Base where you'll find not only aircraft
and flight Crews from the U.S but also
from the UK in Australia working
together during this year's red flag
operation the mission of red flag
is all about readiness and the way that
mice water ensures Readiness is by
developing both relevant and realistic
combat scenarios to train our Air Force
joint and Coalition on warfighters this
exercise provides military air Crews
with intensive air combat drills in a
safe and realistic training environment
[Music]
foreign is the perfect place for it with
12 000 square miles of airspace to use
the goal according to Kevin turret with
the Royal Air Force is to prevent
crucial pilot errors from happening
during a real conflict the most amazing
training opportunity uh that uh that we
can get in the Royal Air Force is the
opportunity to come here and train
across very difficult threats and a very
complex airspace with our two very
principal allies new for this year's
training combat drills over the Pacific
Ocean Jeremy Wright with the U.S Air
Force says building relationships with
other militaries is important in
training they're incredibly
knowledgeable they definitely send to
the best that they have so honestly it's
been a pleasure I've learned a lot for
sure
around 3 000 service members and 100
aircraft will participate in this year's
red flag exercise which will last about
two weeks reporting at Nellis Air Force
Base Brian will 8 News Now